>> COVITZ: All right. Welcome, everybody.
We're really excited to be here with you today
to introduce something that we've been working
really hard on that called the Google Wave
Media APIs. And we're excited to tell you
what this is all about. Wave Media APIs, sort
of, bridge the gap between wave and other
systems. And this is, if you've been, you
know, listening to the other talks that have
happened, you know, yesterday and today that
sort of the theme. We have federation, we
have enterprise talks, we've liberated robots,
we've done lots of things and this is, sort
of, the next step in that process. How do
you get rich content in to and out of wave
and how do you manipulate, play, and have
fun with that content all while still staying
in within wave? Before we get started I wanted
to navigate everybody to the live wave for
this session. There you can find notes being
taken, discussions being had, you can ask
questions. We'll also take questions at the
end of the session from the microphones here
in the audience, so please go there and have
fun while you're enjoying the talk. Just a
quick recap on what wave is. I'm sure after
two days of using wave throughout Google I/O
and the year after we've launched it, it's
probably or hopefully it's clear to you what
wave is really well suited for and we feel
its best suited for collaboration. Collaboration
means many things and collaboration; you can
use collaboration for number of purposes collaborating
on and around business, documents, processes,
and meetings. In the education space, research
projects, different learning sessions, let
a teacher or professor monitor what's going
on with the learning of their students. And
in the consumer space, you can collaborate
on photo albums, party planning, community
groups you name it; everything that you can
collaborate on. What makes wave especially
great is that wave infuses communication in
and around your collaboration. This is what
really steam lines it. You can find out, you
can talk about a particular aspect of a document.
You can focus in on an aspect of that document.
You can also converse about it and lastly
wave is live and real-time. You don't have
to wait to find out what someone thinks about,
what's your typing, they can see that you're
typing right now, they can jump in and they
can interact with you as well. Before I go
to into rich content, I forgot to introduce
myself and my teammates. I'm Seth and this
is Jimin and Phil.
>> LI: Hi.
>> COVITZ: And we're all engineers on the
Google Wave team. Jimin and Phil will be helping
me out a little bit later in this talk going
to go into deeper detail on how all of these
APIs work. In particular, what is rich content?
So you know what a wave is, you know how waves
work. What is rich content? Rich content is
basically any external content from a source
outside of wave. It can be from an external
system, from an external application. It can
be, you know, photos, documents, diagrams;
it can be proprietary file formats that your
enterprise may have, whatever it is that is
rich content. With rich content users expect
to be able to do everything they can do at
rich content on the desktop. They expect to
be able to import it, view it, play it, convert
it to various things, apply transformations
from one format to another format, publish
it to their blog or to their website or their
content management system and synchronize
it with other systems they may have. Just
to give you a little taste, why don't we do
a little demo for you?
So here I am in wave. I'm going to create
a new wave. I'm going to add Jimin and Phil
to this wave and say we're getting hungry
because it's getting a little late, and I'm
going to see if they want to have some Chinese
food. Now typically what would happen at this
point is I would find a PDF of a menu or something
there and I would drag it and upload it to
the wave as this is happening. You can watch
it upload over the network connection. The
PDF is upload and the PDF is converted. Prior
to today what would happen is you would see
the PDF in wave and you would say, "That's
great." You would go and you would download
it and you review it and you start to come
back to the wave to talk about it. Now with
the media APIs, we can import the content
of the PDF directly into Wave. So I'm going
to drag one of my media API robots here called
import PDF to this wave. It's going to scan
the PDF and then replace it with the content
of the wave to quote Vic from this morning.
Boom, there it goes. Now once it's here, I
can, you know, clear up anything that's not
important. Phil and Jimin can come in and
talk about what they like, I can talk about
what I like. We can place our order and enjoy
our Chinese food. So this is an example of
bringing content from another source or actually
from a real document into wave. Now I'm going
to give you another example, maybe a richer
example of how or what we can do with these
APIs and robots that are using these APIs.
I'm going to start a new wave and we're going
to call these slides. We're going to make
some slides. I'm going to add Jimin and Phil
to this wave and each of us is going to collaborate
on a slideshow we want to give. Like what
are we going to do after I/O? So after I/O--hmm.
Should we take a vacation? Jimin is already
reading my mind and she's creating a slide
about what, where we should on the vacation
and how long should we take? Should we take
Larz and Greg with us? I don't know. They
both have thumbs up, they're coming with us.
So, we created a simple thing in wave because
we're not good at really creating presentations.
We just made some bulleted list on things
that we might want to share. And because we're
not great at creating presentations, what
I'd really like to do is I'd really wish there
was a robot out there that could take this
and create a nice presentation for me. And
luckily I have one of those robots here. So
I drag this media API export robot. It's going
to look at the content in the wave and it's
going to create a PowerPoint just like that.
I clicked on it and we'll take a look at it
and here you go. It took the PowerPoint; it
created some nice styling for me, and Phil,
for Phil and Jimin. Eat lots of food, I agree
with that too. So that gives an example of
how we can take that content that was simply
created in wave out of bunch of rich formatting
and styling, export it in another format,
and reattach that content back into the wave.
In a similar vein, you might get presentations
from other people that you want to import
back into wave. So what if we took this presentation
and we pulled it back into wave using an import
robot. And when you see we can stack robots
like this and multiple robots can apply different
transformations. So this robot takes a little
bit more time because it has to process the
information and render it into a series of
images. Thank you. That robot likes to take
its time. And now we have the same PowerPoint
presentation that we collaborated on here
in wave that we can share with our friends.
All made possible by the power of the media
APIs. So introducing the wave media APIs,
what this APIs were offering? For the first
time, give the developer full access to attachments.
Robots can create, fetch, delete attachments
as much as they want, as often as they want,
in any way that they want. They have full
access to the binary data, so they can manipulate
the attachments as well as, you know, other
things. We also are introducing gadgets and
giving gadgets the ability to have access
to these same attachments. If you notice at
the beginning while I was playing the soundtrack
at the beginning of the talk, the soundtrack
was actually pulling from an MP3 that was
loaded into the wave. The gadget was being
used to view the MP3 not host it somewhere
else but the MP3 that I had dragged and dropped
earlier into wave. So you can view documents,
you manipulate documents, you can play media
all within the gadgets, all within the wave.
And lastly, we're going to show you some extensions
on how you can bundle this capabilities into
extensions that can be shared with co-workers
and the other people working in your work
group to get more work done efficiently, more
efficiently. And with that I'm going to hand
it over to Jimin who's going to tell you in
more detail about how the robot APIs works.
>> LI: Thank you, Seth. So what has a wave
robot attachment to APIs? So those are the
APIs that can make wave robot create, delete,
or update attachments from a blip. With this
new functionality, there are a lot more like
new use-cases. For example, wave robot can
now import attachment content from another
attachment into Google Wave. Another example
is that they can export a wave content out
into an attachment, or they can read one attachment
and convert it to one type, from one type
to another type. So first, I'm going to introduce
the read API. So Wave Attachment Read API,
what you can do is you can retrieve attachment
information. So you can gather the attachment
content. There are two ways you can get attachment
content, first way is you use to getters for
the data to get attachment content. Behind
the scene, the getter will first get the attachment
URL and then will fetch the URL content and
then will present the content to you. Of course,
the second way is that you can always do the
same by getting the attachment URL and fetch
the content to yourself. Attachments also
have several attributes. Attachment ID is
a unique ID assigned to the attachment. Attachment
caption is a caption or filename of the attachment.
And the attachment URL is a URL that you can
use to download the attachments. And, of course,
the last one is a MIME Type, which is an Internet
media type. Wave Attachment Read API. One
use-case, as I just mentioned, is you can--during
the import use-case, which it'll first, read
an attachment from Google Wave and then you
read that content and you convert that content
and then you do the import. With this, I'm
going to show you a demo. So first, I'm going
create a new wave and I'm going to call it
the import. And after that, I'm going to drag
a text file and I want to import the content
of the text file into Google Wave. So what
I can do is I can ask my favorite robot called
the import robot to do this. It will read
the attachment content, and will convert that
into string and then will delete the attachment
and replace it with attachment content. So
this is the flow that I just showed to you.
For import to work, user first needs to upload
files and then the robot being added to wave.
And the robot will fetch the binary data and
the robot converts and inserts the content.
And below you can see the details of the flow.
All right, so let's take a closer look at
the code. How does it work? So first, I want
to make sure that I can read the entire wavelet.
So I specify this by using the "context=context.ALL()".
And then after that, I overwrite one function
called on "OnWaveletSelfAdded". This will
be triggered whenever I add a robot to this
wave. And my robot, not only it can do the
import case, it also can do the export case.
To make this happen, I'm using the "proxyingFor".
So, as you can see, one is proxying for the
import. It is act as an import robot. And
the one is proxying for export is act as an
export robot. So let's take a look at the
import function and to see how the robot works
to import the text. So first, it will gather
attachment element. It will gather first the
attachment element of this blip. And then
after that, it will use the "attachment.getData"
to get the attachment data. And it will convert
the attachment data into a string. And then
it will use a replace function to replace
the attachment with the string. So next, I'm
going to talk about attachment write API.
Wave Attachment Write API, what you can do?
You can create an attachment with captioned
and the attachment data in byte array. You
can delete an attachment by removing the corresponding
element. Or you can update the attachment
by replacing it with a new attachment. One
use-case for the attachment write API is the
export case. Where you can create a wave,
you put some content into the wave, and you
can drag an export robot and the robot will
get all the content from the wave and actually
put it out with some attachment and then using
attachment write API to put attachment back
into Google Wave. So I'm going to give you
a demo on that. So this is my import robot
that just created this file. Now, I'm going
to drag my export robot which will read this
content and then create a file based on the
content. And this is the export data text.
When you click and then you can see the text
content. So this is the export flow that I
just did. So first, user creates contents,
after that the user asks robot, and the robot
can work the content and then robot attach
the content. So this is a flow of the export
flow. The user will add as a robot, and the
wave will send robot, add event, the robot
will convert the data and then eventually
attach the content back to Wave. So now you
learn to like write and read API. And with
this write and read API, there's a lot of
things you can do. So one demo I want to show--oh
before I go that far, I'd probably want to
show the code of the export. So for export
code, first, I'm going to iterate over all
the blips in the wavelet. And for each blip
in the wavelet, I'm going to get a blip content
and then I'm going to append that into a string
builder. So after that, I'm going to create
an attachment element. I'll specify one parameter
which is caption and that the other parameter
which is data. So I convert the data to the
byte array. And after that, I call append
to append the attachment to the reply blip.
So with the read and the write API, there's
a lot you can do. So one example I have is
called the Origami Photo Album. So at first,
I needed to take a look at my pictures. And
for this demo to work, I need the help from
my Origami robot. So those are the pictures
I took last year while we visited London.
And I want to show the pictures to my friend
in a nicer format. So for that, the Origami
demo robot will do this. So let's see how
it works. So the Origami Photo Album Robot
will compose two different styles of pictures.
And each picture will have four different--will
compose it by for different small pictures,
and for it to work. So first, it will--using
the read API to get all the image attachment
URLs. After that, the robot will fetch the
URL content itself and then it will resize
the images and then it will compose the images
into two different styles. And each style
will have like four pictures on it. And after
that, the last type is it's going to use attachment
write API to insert the pictures back to the
Wave. So let's see how it works. So here you
go. You have two pictures. I'm going to use
the attachment slideshow to show this picture.
And as you can see these are the palace and
the subway, taxi, and the garden near the
palace. And, of course, the other picture,
you have days of London and nights of London.
And I believe this is the [INDISTINCT] the
fourth installation of the [INDISTINCT] which
was released last May. And. it was on, at
[INDISTINCT] like last October. So the next
example I want to show you of using the read
and the write API, it is called the Bar Chart.
So I have a file called the World Population.
So if I take a look at this file and you can
see our world population for the last 30 years.
From year '80, we have 4.4 billion people
and then last year we have around like 6.7
billion people. And, I want to show this,
you know, a nice chart so that I can see the
trend clearly. For that, I'm going to drag
the bar chart robot. So this robot will use
attachment read API to read the file and after
that it converts the file into some chart
and it's using the attachment write API to
create a chart, to insert a chart back into
Wave, and this is the chart. So this bar chart
robot, what does it do? Let's recap here.
So first, it creates the bar chart based on
the text file data. So first it will read
the attachment data and then it create bar
chart and then it will insert the attachment
back into Google Wave. And with this, I'm
going to hand over to Phil talking about the
Gadget Viewer API.
>> LIAO: Thank you. So as Seth just showed
you an MP3 player is a viewer and, but you
could also build viewers for in lining PDFs
or spreadsheets. Now I'm going to show you
how you would use a viewer as an end user.
So first you install the viewer.
It is already installed so I'm going to uninstall
it and install it again but, you don't have
to do that. The first time you install a viewer
it would ask you for permission but this is
second time so it remembers and it just goes
through. Okay. Now I'll start a new wave and
I'm going to take a text file,
and drag it. Okay. So I have a text file and
now the user would say, open the menu, and
expand with the ASCII viewer. And you have
a cat that waves its tail. All right, okay.
So end of demo. So when you click, open with,
we involved the gadget, the viewer and we
give it that attachment URL and that viewer
would take that URL, download the data and
do something with it then it displays it to
the user. So that is the viewer API. Basically,
we give you the URL and you do something with
it. So, this is the complete text of a text
viewer. It's very simple, it's a normal OpenSocial
gadget that uses wave API and let me take
you through the steps. So first, you'll initialize
the gadget, in this initialization code you
tell wave that you're interested in the state
change event. So when wave opens your gadget,
it'll tell you that you have a new state attribute
called attachment URL and it has a new value.
So now you can do something with it. So in
this case, we're making a request to get the
contents of the URL and when that's finished,
we have a callback on URL fetch and we take
the text file and put it in the content container.
Now you have a simple text viewer and it's
actually quite useful. So, when you have a
system crash and you have a multiple JFile,
you don't want to email it back and forth
and have coded text after coded text and coded
text, instead you would view your text file,
your log for JFile in the wave and then you
could discuss it in wave so you don't get
this email back and forth, it's very useful.
Now if you're doing the MP3 player then you
would insert a flash gadget and give it the
URL and it will play music for you. We have
something more complicated you sent that URL
through AJAX to some server and it does some
processing and it makes a nice presentation
for you. So now that you have viewers and
importers, exporters you will like share them
with your friends, co-workers so you would
make extensions, package them as extensions
so that you have an installer that you could
share and let me show you. So, the first thing
you want to do is you go to your featured
extensions gallery and you find the one that's
for developers only. So, this one is the extensions
that let you install other extensions so when
you install it out you will see the installer
in your toolbar, so. When I create a new wave,
this little icon here is your extensions installer.
Okay. Okay. So now it'd ask me for a manifest.
So, I'm going to type in the manifest, the
address of the manifest. And, actually, I
already have installed it so it comes back
that says, do you want to uninstall it? But,
I'm not going through that again. So now you
can share this wave with everyone and they
could also install the text viewer. So let
me go back to the cat. And I could open it
with the regular text viewer, so it shows
you how I actually created the animation.
And we could go back to the waving cat with
the other viewer. Okay. So this is the installer
site, and now, let me show what goes into
the manifest. So the first half is the viewer
manifest and the important attribute here,
the important tag is the attachment code.
It's a new element we put in our manifest.
The attachment could tell us the wave that
your extension is going to work with attachments.
And in this manifest, you tell it a name and
you give it the address of the gadget since
that's all you need to install a viewer. Now
for an importer you would use this manifest
at the bottom and the important thing you're
looking for is the add participants action
that tell us wave that this extension will
act as a participant in the wave. Now in this
tag you'll have a Participant ID and it, you
give it the name of the robot. In this case,
it's a media-api@appspot.com and then you'll
add the import-text to tell wave that this
extension is going to use the media API robot
to import text. So as you saw in Jimin's code,
she has one robot that act both as an importer
and exporter, in this manifest create a user
where that robot is acting on behalf of the
import text user in that context. Okay, now
Seth will summarize.
>> COVITZ: Thanks, Phil, and thanks, Jimin.
Just to summarize the detailed changes of
what we've added to the robots and gadgets
APIs. Specifically for robots, we've added
a new element, the attachment element with
the following properties. This element acts
much like the other elements in wave. You
can insert them, replace them, append them,
delete them, et cetera. The difference is
the data property because the data property
actually holds a byte stream which is the
content of your attachment and that's how
you can both create attachments and modify
attachments, so create a new attachments or
delete them. For the Gadgets API, specifically
what we've added is this attachment URL state
injection. That to be clear, this is sort
of the convention to the gadget to let it
know I'm being used in the capacity of URL.
When the user clicks the Open With menu, selects
the gadget that they want to view this content
with, we instantiate the gadget and inject
that property in there. The gadget checks
for the existence of the property and then
knows they can now fetch the attachment data
and render the attachment in line within the
wave. And lastly, we added extensions for
import, export, and viewer. Look for those
extensions to be more entirely integrated
into the user experience for uploading, downloading
files in the future. With this, I just want
to again say that this is another step in
terms of integration. The theme of Google
Wave at Google I/O, one of the themes is getting
work done with groups of people and to help
that, you often need to integrate with other
systems and we've showed you a number of ways
at the Enterprise Talk, these robots and gadgets
to do that. In the federation talk to federated
with other systems. And here, with the media
APIs to be able to actually both get data
content, binary data content into and out
of wave for the purposes of importing into
wave and collaborating on and around it or
for the purposes of synchronizing with other
systems that data and content. So we want
to let, everyone go to code.google.com/apis/wave,
there's a new documentation there. There's
also a new robot client libraries for Java
and Python that you can download and start
playing with these APIs today. And with that,
we're going to switch over to the live wave
and see what sort of questions we have. We'll
also take questions from the audience, if
anybody wants to come up to the speaker and
ask questions.
>> Hi, can I specify in gadget manifest to
the MIME type to which it applies of URL?
>> COVITZ: So, the question was, can we apply
specific, have the gadget apply only just
specific MIME types? That's not currently
implemented...
>> Uh-hmm.
>> COVITZ: ...but that is coming soon. It
is definitely our intent as the users will
have lots of gadget viewers and they'll have
lots of import and export robots that it clearly
doesn't make sense for each robot to be able
to apply to each type so we'd be able to narrow
it down for the types that only that robot
or gadget is comfortable manipulating.
>> And what about MIME type assigning? So,
for instance, I upload some, my preparatory
format, it has a known extension for Google
Wave. How would I, what is, I think it will
application binary or something, so how will
I, can I get the URL? Will it have the extension,
I mean, just windows extension or something?
>> COVITZ: Right, for custom file, for file
types, we haven't really, we don't really
have a solution for that yet, but we will
be working on that.
>> Uh-hmm.
>> COVITZ: ...because we want to be able to
detect the MIME type on our end. We also do
anti-virus checking to make sure that the
content is safe to be included in the wave.
But for priority formats where we won't possibly
be able to detect all the formats and we will
want to have a way for you to specify the
formats so then your associated viewer and
other things can act on them.
>> Well, at least, can I have, change the
extensional regex on name or something?
>> COVITZ: Some of that works on a regex on
a name?
>> Yeah.
>> COVITZ: That's a very good idea. I think
we can look into that.
>> Okay, thank you.
>> COVITZ: Next question.
>> I saw there are other two properties on
the attachment element with attachment URL
and data. And I don't think I quite got the
section [INDISTINCT]. Is that, are those two
different options for the same, kind of thing,
is that like, given source and data URI syntax
sort of thing so can either embed it directly
or have for or do URL?
>> COVITZ: Do you want to answer that?
>> LI: I can't quite get your question, can
you repeat that part?
>> Are the data properties in the attachment
URL properties on the...
>> LI: Oh yeah, so, is your question is about
what's the difference between data property
and the attachment URL property?
>> Yeah.
>> LI: So attachment URL is just a regular
URL or a string like any other URL. So with
this URL, you can use URL fetch here to gather
data. And the attachment to data is that real
attachment of data in a binary array.
>> COVITZ: So to go, to add it more to a Jimin's
answer, they both refer to the same thing.
So you have the URL and you can then go fetch
the content yourself or you can say get data
and it will fetch the content for you. So,
in some cases you may want your robot to process
the data right there in which case you might
just say get data. In other cases you may
want to send the URL off to another server
that you own and have that process the data
and return it back. So, in that case, you
might just want to send the URL and not the
data itself.
>> Okay, so if attachment URL is not empty
then the data property should be identical
to the content at the URL?
>> COVITZ: Exactly.
>> Okay, thank you.
>> COVITZ: Question?
>> Yes, when you do a replace on a attachment,
do you get a different URL?
>> COVITZ: When you do a, when you replace
an attachment within the wave, do you get
a new URL?
>> Yeah, do you get a new URL or, and does
the old one still viable?
>> COVITZ: Yes. So, in wave, attachments are
immutable which means when you change the
attachment, you're actually making a new attachment.
And the attachments, the old attachment remains
for the purposes of playback. So you can always
go back to playback in history and you want
to see the attachment at that state in the
past, so yes. Wherever you create a new attachment,
you will get a new URL or if you replace one.
>> Have a new ID?
>> COVITZ: Yes.
>> LI: Yes.
>> COVITZ: You'll have a new ID.
>> So if [INDISTINCT], there's no way to [INDISTINCT]?
>> COVITZ: The question again?
>> [INDISTINCT] there's no way [INDISTINCT]?
>> COVITZ: So the question was if a robot
updates in attachment, how to link the two
together? So, currently, there wouldn't be
linked other than the history of the playback.
So your robot would have to keep track of
the [INDISTINCT] of the attachment IDs itself.
Question?
>> If you add more than one attachment files,
the attachment to URL, does attachment to
URL returns array of URLs?
>> COVITZ: For the robot?
>> I mean, we can add more than one attachment
file to it.
>> COVITZ: Yes, you can attach as many attachments
as you like.
>> Yeah? So, but, the key for attachment is
just attachment URL.
>> COVITZ: The key is the attachment ID?
>> Behind.
>> COVITZ: Or the attachment URL, yes.
>> So, how should I handle more than one attachment
files?
>> COVITZ: So, the question was how to add
more than one attachment? So in the API example
that Jimin showed, you could create a new
attachment element and then you can insert
it anywhere within the wave. So if you want
to attach more than one thing, you just create
more than one element and insert them in series
or in multiple blips or in the same blip or
whatever you would like.
>> Okay, thank you.
>> COVITZ: I'll take a question from the [INDISTINCT],
what kind of limits can we expect for attachment
size, number of types embeddability? So in
terms of size, the current size for an attachment
in wave is 20 megabytes, and as we continue
to work with this, we may look to expand that
but that's the current limit. In terms of
number, you can add as many attachments as
you like until you fill the user quota, a
user's quota. We do attachment duplication
detection on the backend. So if you attach
the same attachment in multiple times in separate
ways, you won't, that won't be charge against
your quota, but eventually, you will run out
of quota if you attach a large number of objects.
In terms of type as we have said before, you
can attach literally any type at all. Embeddability,
I'm not quite sure with that means. But the
attachments can be embedded in the wave so
you can see them. And of course with the viewers,
you can actually view them as embedded objects
in the wave. I guess, that answers that question.
Audience question?
>> Yes, since waves are essentially XML documents,
right? So this is the data base64 encoded
or how exactly is that included there?
>> COVITZ: So, data in wave is XML. The data
for the attachment is stored in binary, in
our backend servers. In terms of fetching
the data, it does HTTPget back to our servers
to fetch the binary data into the robot so
it's not base64 encoded when you have it,
when you add it.
>> So that data property of the attachment
element is not sent with the wave it's retrieve
on what, when needed?
>> COVITZ: That's correct, that's correct.
>> Okay.
>> COVITZ: Now, when the attachment is created,
it is actually encoded in base64 and return
back and the response to the event when it
was created. So we do pass it in that operation
and the JSON back to our server. But when
it's fetched, so in the read case, it's pulled
directly from the server as binary.
>> Okay, so there's a separate request for
each attachment in addition to the...
>> COVITZ: Right.
>> ...initial. Okay.
>> COVITZ: Right, as you may have heard with
robots, you can specify which data and how
much data you want to pulled down in response
to an event. And we didn't feel that users
would want bandwidth soaked up with large
attachments coming down in response to every
event so that's why we go and fetch the attachments
only on demands when the APIs is called.
>> Okay, so are the attachments separate,
in a sort of separate file or stored from
the wave...
>> COVITZ: That's correct.
>> ...wavelets and...?
>> All right, thank you.
>> COVITZ: And there's one more question here
on the [INDISTINCT] on the moderator which
is can we use that in-browser datastore for
large media files? So we do use that in-browser
datastore. We currently use gears to buffer
some of the files as they're being uploaded.
We're not currently using the datastore for
files that are downloaded but it's something
that we've talked about and also we're looking
HTML5 to be able to cache more of those files
on the client to improve performance of paging
and looking at large numbers of images in
attachments and things like that. Are there
any more questions? Well, with that, we want
to take everyone for staying for our talk.
We really appreciate it. We hope you all tryout
these APIs and make some really great and
exciting things. Thank you very much.